[Musique]
et voilà le thème fort oui chéri vous
l'avez dit le festival de cannes démarre
aujourd'hui on va voir il ya tous les
hôtels normalement pour avoir un hôtel
une chambre d'hôtel au festival de
cannes en ce moment c'est impossible
ce que je voudrais qu'on fasse c'est
qu'on appelle des hôtels très connu vous
allez appeler par exemple dire suivez
les rives et naïm vous allez voir on va
voir si vous allez avoir une chambre
vous allez dire chut mathieu deux hommes
ont rappelé plusieurs hôtels on va voir
celui qui arrive à avoir une chambre
pour le festival de cannes
on n'a pas le tout de suite un hôtel qui
s'appelle l'hôtel martinez c'est l'hôtel
le long c'est un des hôtels les plus
huppés
là c'est le ciel tonnes c'est la faulx
l'aï attaqué jamais la laisser tomber la
tension du bétail mais valve mais si les
vous dites c'est valérie bénaïm jeu la
jambre l'arrêt ce week end
d'accord et vous y allez un allez venez
études alors c'est mon bénin là oui
c'est bon c'est bon mais là attention on
a vérifié si ça répondait lourdes et
mercy nous donne à découvrir à vérifier
c'est à dire qu'ils vont répondre dans
le monde oui bonjour madame je vous
appelle parce que j'ai un impératif je
m'appelle valérie bénaïm et j'ai
absolument absolument absolument besoin
d'une chambre chez vous ce week end je
sais qu'on est en plein festival de
cannes mais c'est justement pour ça non
mais attendez je descends pour ses
huîtres absolument besoin
mais oui mais y'a pas que vous avez
besoin de chambre non mais moi ma de
mademoiselle ou madame
allô allô
[Applaudissements]
en plus c'était très mal fait à plein
d'infos tel match d'ailleurs montré les
images du match et de voir la vie
bretonne c'est parti les magic stone
jessica majestiks cas de succès les
barrières ne mentionne d'ailleurs ce
matin nous vous prions de faire
bonjour cendras et matthieu delormeau de
ses huit vous allez bien bon très bien
sandra il faut absolument une chambre je
descends avec monsieur hanouna pour le
festival de cannes
il me faut actuellement une chambre ce
soir est ce que c'est possible ou en
fait je serai seul bien venir plus tard
lui il faudrait une jambe après dix mois
faites vite merci beaucoup en fait on
lui dit rien ben non mais attends le
sésame à nouveau moi j'avais des jambes
mais aussi dans votre job lui même
qu'une dissous dit l'appelle et lui
disait si jeune champion de norvège de
la chance allô oui bonjour c'est
matthieu delormeau de ses visites juin à
voir sandra vous allez bien alors s'il
vous plaît il faudrait absolument une
chambre pour vraiment pour ce soir c'est
très important pour le festival de
cannes enfin pour ce week-end pour être
plus précis ce soir combien pour ce week
end
je tourne vers las tourner une émission
pour à cyril hanouna il faut absolument
le champ pour ce week-end crois que
c'est possible
j'ai pas le choix le week-end ça va être
compliqué à partir de quelle date elle à
partir de demain à partir de vendredi de
vendre moi et l écart est mignonne
merkel sur le lundi absolument merci
beaucoup c'est gentil
[Applaudissements]
ils viennent aider à nous à toutes les
races
oui sammaritano bouteilles de vinaigre
entre les cases en arménie mais ben haim
s'était passé avec bas du dos s'était
dit qu'on fasse de castaldi a fait
évidemment ce star bah oui mais avec ton
temps au pape les a pas d'ouverture d'un
paquet applique la double lame à double
peine moyen 2 s'ils répondent pas de
cassure ou non
oui allô oui gilles et moi de nous avoir
fait patienter jusqu'à une autre
possibilité
ce week-end nous sommes d'ores et déjà
complet une bâtisse madame comment c'est
quoi votre prénom c'est cyril hanouna
caroline bonjour ça va caroline merci
d'avoir refusé matthieu delormeau merci
beaucoup c'est bravo majesty quoi bon
vous avez atteint votre qualité
non
benjamin castaldi c'est parti bada
magané on l'appelle le carlton al bundy
le carlton symbole c'est 1000 de plus
l'agent banon mais si des morts c'est
bon ben si c'est bon on peut pas en fait
on n'a pas acquis la carte donne toi tu
es parti après que vous appellera un
hôtel vous avez hélas plus rien tu vas
aller chez pierre & vacances tu attends
ça m'a aidé
oui bon sens et benzéma gastellier
l'appareil et je vous dérange pas les
régions s'il vous plaît ça donc on sait
pas très bien mais le carlton de crédit
à l'omaha temps j'aime pas ça du tout
alors oui allô oui bonjour bonjour je
vous rappelle que confirmer la
réservation qui commençait demain soir
c'est pas beau ça
non non non non ça c'est du mytho sagem
pas mal au coude
hélas hélas flag et tout le jeu sur ma
relation
là
atténue le thé nul et nul à l'aller on
appelle tout de suite d'un hôtel pour
isabelle morini bosc à un réglage et
moselle d'allumer en plus mal les allées
où la belle isabelle pour toi vas-y oui
appel bienvenue et de vie que vous tous
d'origine du mal
elle formule 1 merci et bravo j'ai pas
qu'elles ont checké l'hôtel l'aï lavé
qu'on s'appelle en aurait coûté à 106
après quoi la matca l'hôtel il ya
quelqu'un toujours dans l'équipe alors
oui allô allô boubou douter oui bonjour
il est vrai dans la mairie du mas est
redoutée
je m'en doutais quoi quel hôtel si je
tombais pas mal et moi parce que là je
vous appelle en plein boum c'est la
formation du gouvernement sait plus du
tout où j'en suis dans laquelle hôtel
suis-je pardon juste avant qu'on ait
tout bien l'arche où ça marche avec
cyril hanouna ou pas allaiter carlton
rappelle-t-on
nathan pourquoi le carlton cole
automatique majestic asiatiques les mecs
alors là alors là ça me ferait bien
chier que j'ai une chambre est pas tout
à fait au point
beaucoup plus connu au monde avoir
patienté kutcher pour vous oui bonjour
c'est monsieur hanouna cyril je vous
appelle parce que j'ai un gros problème
j'ai vraiment besoin d'une chambre ce
week-end vraiment si la paire important
est ce que vous pensez que vous pouvez
me débrouiller sa 1ère fois que je
préfère bouquet ben voilà ce qu'en fait
je sais qu'il est libéré merci merci
[Applaudissements]
sait rien encore de la musique
germanique les est ici c'est à lasbordes
qui est de josé gil soit en train de
jeter moque l'argent justice pour les
winners losers le talent alors attention
attention on va voir la direction
est-ce qu'on va avoir cette journée en
famille oui bonsoir c'est monsieur
hanouna cyril excusez moi de vous
déranger
j'aimerais avoir une chambre absolument
pour ce week end je me prends un petit
peu tard mais il faut absolument que je
sois sûr kahn ce week end en fait et
voilà j'aimerai je fais appel à vous
voilà je suis en galère
est ce que c'est possible ou pas alors
nous on adore rêve aura perdu tellement
parce qu'on adore vraiment reprenne
union mais nous sommes vraiment complet
c'est vrai et je sais que je sais qu'il
ya mathieu delormeau qui vous a appelé
également oui le lui c'est non c'est sûr
est-ce que vous commandez maya même pas
même une petite chambre n'importe quoi
pouvait pas voir ça avec monsieur
desseigne
[Rires]
le premier fait marcher les relations
madame parce que c'est pas possible on
m'appelle can i phone et oui madame
c'est pas possible on va voir ce qu'on
peut faire c'est vrai on peut voir ce
qu'on veut nous laisser vos coordonnées
on vous rappelle alors est-ce qu'on peut
m'appeler noah est ce que vous pouvez
m'appeler je voulais c'est mon numéro de
portable on va vous laisser tout faire
et vous m'appelez même pendant
l'émission d'accord c'est une lame
important un peu d'accord d'accord vous
m'appelez pendant rien sur mon portail
merci c'est hyper-important salut fanni
j'attends de vos nouvelles je suis pas
bien je suis au bout du rouleau
sauvez-moi fanning sauvez moi mais on va
voir s'il n'y va pas on aura un appel on
espère pendant l'émission
avec cette affaire est ce qu'on va avoir
réussi et on va réussir à avoir une
chambre
l'égérie et vous verrez on va voir et si
j'ai la chambre et bien vous la prendrez
vous avez envie d'y aller ce week-end
c'est vrai oui ah bah oui je viens qui
venait justement avez vous comme à moi
non mais votre budget
arashiro pour l'origine la mission
remettre ça me coûte la wii 2 voilà
joueur jamais revoir à center parc c'est
au campanile
on se retrouve tout de suite pour
l'émission ça va être la folie a tout de
suite le beau temps revient en forme
exceptionnelle a tout de suite